[Applauso]
la domanda che mi sono sentita a porre
più spesso è sempre stata di che cosa ti
occupi
quando rispondevo archeologia dall'altra
parte la reazione era sempre più o meno
la stessa o ma che bello archeologia
avrei voluto anch'io studiare
archeologia i dinosauri ma di quello si
occupano i paleontologi e non gli
archeologi gli egizi
quando poi rispondevo che in realtà sono
un archeologa medievista la reazione era
sempre a
la prima volta che ho visitato uno scavo
archeologico avevo sei anni e la mia
maestra mirella accompagnato la mia
classe una prima elementare a vedere gli
scavi che il professor tombolani stava
facendo e nel sito archeologico delle
antiche mura a jesolo paese
chiudete gli occhi e immaginate due case
coloniche un'aia con all'interno i resti
di una cattedrale romanica
monumentale
nessuno sullo scavo nessun archeologo
una recensione arancione dietro cui
sbirciare e le galline del proprietario
che razzolavano tranquillamente tra le
buche e le mura dell'edificio antiche
non si capiva assolutamente nulla non so
come abbia fatto una bambina di 6 anni a
rimanere affascinato da quel luogo
fatto sta che in quel momento ha deciso
che da grande non avrei fatto la
veterinaria ma avrei fatto l'archeologa
che poi vi dirò mi è andata anche meglio
perché quando porto la mia gatta dalla
veterinaria devota parmi gli occhi con
tutte e due le mani perché mi fa
impressione qualsiasi cosa
quindi archeologia la tv ha sempre dato
un'idea duplice dell'archeologo da un
lato i documentari che mostrano questi
studiosi con il pennellino di solito in
luoghi carini che comodamente in dieci
anni mettono in luce una statua integra
un mosaico perfetto un muro diritto
dall'altra indiana jones lo conoscete
tutti che schiocca la sua frusta e
infila le mani imposti ori di piani di
insetti enormi bene vi dirò che la
frusta sullo scavo non mi è mai capitato
di usarla però di insetti ne ho visto
una quantità davvero davvero esasperante
in realtà nel corso degli scavi mi è
capitato di fare come potete vedere la
mano vale ho fatto la lava cocci di
solito con l'acqua ghiacciata in
giornate freddissime
ho fatto la scribacchina mi è capitato
di fare la scala la reggia il telo per
fare ombra durante le foto ho fatto
anche il pastore di pecore allo stato
brado sullo scavo e quando poi lo scavo
si riduceva così per la troppa pioggia
ho fatto il pescatore
sono stati anni difficilissime
in realtà vi ho mostrato queste immagini
un po goliardiche per farvi capire che
l'archeologo si deve adattare molto alle
situazioni agli ambienti che incontra
anche perché di solito l'ambiente non
rende più facile il lavoro che svolgiamo
la maggior parte delle volte ci
ritroviamo a lavorare nella misura più
totale o nel fango fino alle ginocchia
ad ogni modo quando mi sono iscritta
all'università ca foscari di venezia per
studiare archeologia ho capito che il
mestiere dell'archeologo ha molte più
sfaccettature di quello che sembra
archeologia significa studio dell'antico
ma il concetto di antichità e molto
molto ampio per alcuni si tratta di
rinvenimento e studio di oggetti di
pregio come gioielli o statue per altri
significa studio di cose rotte in veneto
si dice rovinasse pietre o cozzi in
realtà è vero l'archeologo studia la
cultura materiale e attraverso i
manufatti riesce a recuperare
informazioni su quella che è la società
che li ha prodotti utilizzati
sull'economia sui commerci
prendete ad esempio queste due immagini
qui abbiamo due ciotole in ceramica
sigillata di produzione africana quindi
entrambe prodotte con una tecnica
codificata entrambe prodotte nelle
botteghe ubicate all'incirca nel nord
dell'attuale tunisia
entrambe prodotte all'incirca nel quinto
secolo tutte e due sono state caricate
su navi che contenevano grano e
contenitori di olio che hanno solcato il
mar mediterraneo e il mar adriatico
però mentre la ciotola di destra ci
parla di un consumo individuale dei
pasti quella di sinistra ci parla di un
consumo collettivo
solitamente in ambito familiare questo
per mostrarvi come due oggetti
apparentemente simili rinvenire
rinvenuti nello stesso sito si possano
parlare di due culture alimentari
completamente
completamente diverse
però archeologia significa anche
comprensione e resa di relazioni
spaziali e temporali tra oggetti ai
bambini che vengono in scavo racconto
del contesto dell'ambiente come di una
torta una torta composta da diversi
strati di pan di spagna di colori e
gusti diversi
inframmezzati da strati di crema
pasticcera di colori e gusti diversi con
il mezzo granella di nocciole o
frammenti di cioccolato questo è come se
tra un contesto nel suo complesso quello
che fa l'archeologo e andare a
distruggere ogni singolo strato per
analizzare le relazioni tra i diversi
strati e con quello che c'è al suo
interno
quindi possiamo dire che quello che
facciamo è cercare di ricostruire i vari
passaggi evolutivi siano essi opera
dell'uomo o della natura e cercare di
recuperare tutte le informazioni tutti i
dati possibili che ci permettono di
ricostruire il deposito che stiamo
andando ad indagare questo lo facciamo
attraverso una minuziosa documentazione
anche grafica quindi con ricostruzioni
2d 3d o con l'ausilio di applicazioni
informatiche e questo può essere
applicato sia al singolo scavo sia dei
paesaggi quindi a degli spazi molto
molto più ampi però l'archeologo si
avvale sempre del supporto di
specialisti in altri ambiti come ad
esempio l'antropologia o la
geomorfologia
oppure con l'aiuto di studiosi di
scienza che si occupano di effettuare
delle analisi specifiche sugli oggetti
prendete ad esempio lo scavo di un
villaggio di un insediamento
se noi ci troviamo di fronte ai resti di
edifici possiamo acquisire delle
informazioni su quelle che sono le
tecniche edilizie i commerci e le cave
di materiali
se rinveniamo invece dei manufatti
possiamo ottenere delle informazioni su
quella che era la vita quotidiana sulle
attività lavorative sui commerci
sull'economia se invece andiamo a
studiare ad esempio dei resti botanici
delle ossa di animali
abbiamo informazioni su colture
allevamento e anche su alimentazione
se invece ci troviamo di fronte allo
scavo di un'area cimiteriale riusciamo
ad acquisire informazioni sulla
popolazione che in antico viveva in quel
luogo quindi età di morte sesso traumi
patologie ma anche legami familiari
attraverso le analisi del dna
oppure informazioni sulla dieta o sulla
provenienza attraverso l'analisi degli
isotopi stabili se poi invece vogliamo
capire com'era
l'ambiente in quel periodo ci avvaliamo
del supporto di giò morphology e palin
ology che si occupano poi dello studio
dei pollini
allora
personalmente ve lo posso dire negli
anni me mi sento molto fortunata perché
ho avuto la possibilità di studiare
molti contesti e di lavorare con persone
davvero davvero preparato in questo
ambito
però mi sento fortunata soprattutto
perché ho avuto la possibilità da quando
collaboro con ca foscari di lavorare con
gli studenti universitari quindi di
insegnare loro un metodo e un mestiere e
di occuparmi di ricerca che non è
scontato ed è proprio in questo ambito
che ho avuto modo di lavorare con le
persone che mi hanno insegnato
praticamente tutto quello che so il
primo tra tutti
il mio professore il professor sauro
gelichi con cui mi sono laureata con cui
lavoro da vent'anni che davvero una vita
ma poi ci sono anche le mie amiche
colleghe di tutta una vita alessandra
sontuosi anita granzow ed è con loro che
circa dieci anni fa ho iniziato questa
fantastica esperienza sia lavorativa che
personale che riguarda proprio lo scavo
di jesolo in questa slide potete vedere
una piccolissima parte del lavoro che
abbiamo svolto in alto vedete una parte
del dello scavo dell'insediamento
tardoantico quarto quinto secolo si
tratta di una mansi una stazione di
soldi sosta mentre più in basso vedete
la ricostruzione che abbiamo fatto
dell'isola sempre tra quarto e quinto
secolo grazie all'ausilio e al supporto
di tutti gli specialisti nel settore
l'archeologo in realtà può fare il suo
lavoro ovunque perché di fatto scava
ricostruisce e analizza però avere la
possibilità di lavorare dove sei nata e
cresciuta e capire finalmente che cosa
nascondono quei terreni che tu guardi
con far interrogativo da tutta una vita
è un'altra storia e poi c'è un'altra
nota positiva del fatto di aver potuto
lavorare a jesolo e cioè che finalmente
mio padre ha capito che lavoro facessi
nei cantieri edili a venezia li vedeva
anche accanto ai muratori gli architetti
restauratori quindi sarà convinto che
avesse studiato architettura un restauro
quindi devo ammettere che è rimasto un
pochino male quando ho capito che ho
studiato tanti anni per spostare terra
però in realtà era anche molto
orgoglioso di quello che stavamo facendo
e devo ammettere che lo ero anch'io
adesso vorrei farvi vedere un breve
video che vi racconta appunto il mio
spazio lavorativo
questa è l'area archeologica delle
antiche mura di cui vi parlavo prima
sullo sfondo il centro di casero paese e
la laguna i terreni più in alto erano
occupati da spazi acquei dalle valli
mentre i terreni che vedete adesso
questi sconfinati davanti erano occupati
dall isola di cui avete visto la
ricostruzione e qui stiamo andando verso
lo scavo del monastero
mauro che è quello che ci sta impegnando
negli ultimi anni questo è il mio spazio
lavoro attivo ma è anche il mio spazio
del cuore questa per me è casa non lo
trovate un posto bellissimo
per me è stupendo
grazie
e molto difficile trovare le parole per
farvi capire che cosa significhi
effettivamente avere la possibilità di
conoscere le proprie radici in prima
persona
devo ammettere che entusiasmante sapere
che tra i miei compaesani sono la prima
che vede le scoperte quotidiane
però per me è anche motivo di gioia e di
orgoglio sapere che loro possono
conoscere qualcosa della loro storia
attraverso i miei occhi e le mie parole
i miei racconti
ed è davvero indescrivibile quando se i
bambini che gli adulti quando vengono in
scavo ti guardano con questi occhi
increduli mentre cerchi di fargli capire
come poteva essere un paesaggio nei
tempi antichi o come doveva essere un
edificio che ormai non c'è più vi
racconto questo breve aneddoto il primo
anno di scavo
le prime due settimane il terreno era
duro se consuma facevamo un po fatica a
capire come come fosse la situazione non
si vedevano i colori sembrava di trovare
dei livelli di bonifica quindi pensavamo
di aver fatto un enorme buco nell'acqua
io mancavo dallo scavo da un paio di
giorni a un certo punto alessandro hanno
chiamato che sono michela urgenza di
parlare con me
insomma quando sono arrivata sullo scavo
mi sono visto i ragazzi stavano mettendo
in luce le fondazioni di una piccola a
casa con accanto un focolare e il fianco
una rifiutai a un busto di frammenti di
anfore ecco in quel momento non ho più
pensato che ero lì a fare un lavoro non
ho pensato alla mia professionalità e ho
pianto
ed è così che mi sento ancora oggi
commossa di fronte a quelli che sono i
resti delle antiche mura di san mauro di
fronte alle scoperte quotidiane che
facciamo sullo scavo c'è una cosa che vi
vorrei leggere dovrei condividerla con
voi una cosa molto personale ed è una
lettera che ho scritto in un momento un
po particolare della mia vita sia
lavorativa che che personale spero che
insomma vi aiuti a capire come mi sento
di fronte a questa grande opportunità
che che ho avuto
caro professore ho visto il titolo che
ha scelto per il libro su jesolo il
limina mi sono commossa vorrei
ringraziarla molto moltissimo quello
davvero uno spazio di transizione perché
oltre alla cattedrale non c'è più nulla
che ricordi il passato e quella chiesa è
l'unico baluardo rimasto in quel luogo a
memoria di un tempo forse glorioso forse
no a seconda di come si vogliono leggere
gli eventi ma anche il luogo del ricordo
pron jesolano che osserva la chiesa di
sting ogni singola crepa riconosce le
nuove e così spera che non crolli
l'unico testimone di qualcosa che non
esiste più di qualcosa che in realtà si
può solo immaginare si guarda intorno e
si chiede come fosse che ci fosse e
perché non ci sia più nulla e luogo che
fa pensare ad un momento in cui quel
paese era uguale e diverso allo stesso
tempo è uno spazio eliminare che
rappresenta il nostro passato e che le
persone possono conoscere attraverso il
nostro lavoro e i nostri occhi
adesso il ricordo ovvero su quello avize
l'anno perché glielo abbiamo dato noi e
poi caro professore il mio luogo dei
ricordi è il luogo dei ricordi di una
bimba di 6 anni che decidete da grande
vuole fare l'archeologa e che poi ce la
fa un lavoro che ha scelto e che le è
costato fatica è il mio luogo dei
ricordi perché lì ci sono le mie radici
perché papa ci teneva particolarmente
che riuscissimo in questo progetto e lui
non c'è più
forse non riuscirò mai a spiegarle tutti
i significati che ha per me questo lembo
di terra solitario ma vorrei
ringraziarla ancora una volta
infinitamente e vorrei ringraziare con
la bambina che ha sei anni ha deciso di
correre incontro l'archeologia grazie a
tutti
grazie